So in our polar representation,
this purplish line here is going to
be defined by two quantities.
One of them is just this distance, d.
This is the distance of a line to
the origin, the perpendicular distance.
It's the distant to the closest
point on the line to the origin.
And the second parameter, so
that first parameter is d, and
the second parameter's theta.
which is just the angle,
that this perpendicular makes with
the x-axis, or if you want, you
can have it be the angle that the line
makes with the axis, doesn't matter.
You just have to pick an angle.
So basically what we have now is
a polar representation of an angle.
And a distance.
In such a representation,
by doing just a little bit of math,
you can basically see that the dot
product of any point on the line xy.
Dotted with the cosine theta, sine theta
location of this normal is equal to d.
There's a lot of ways to do it but
basically you can show that if you
formulate it this way, that x
cosine(theta) + y sine(theta) = d.
So it's a lot, not a lot,
it's a little bit ugly.
Well, it's beautiful if
you like trigonometry.
It's ugly if you like algebra.
It's a little bit more ugly than
the y equals mx plus b formulation.
But it doesn't have this problem that
any of our lines are ill-defined.
This is a perfectly fine way
of representing any line.
You can have any direction you want.
Theta can go however it wants to go.
And you can be,
you can go right through the origin.
D can be zero, or
it can get as big as you need it to go.
One of the interesting things now is
if you take a look at this equation.
If I know x and y, what I have
left in terms of d and theta.
Is a sinusoid, all right?
Which is why we say that a point in
image space is now a sinusoid in Hough
space, and we'll see an example
of that in a minute.
See, before, we had this beautiful
duality of a point in image space was
a line in Hough space, and a point in
Hough space was a line in image space.
Well, because we've introduced this
cosines and sines, it's still a duality,
but it's no longer simply
between points and lines.
One other comment about this, there's
a redundancy or an ambiguity here.
Let me draw it to you this way.
Here's d, so
if d can only be positive, this line has
to be able to spin all the way around.
So theta would have to go from zero
to two pi, zero to 360 degrees.
But If d could be positive or negative.
Then theta only has to
go from zero to pi.
Or zero to minus pi and
how you draw that.
The idea is you'd only need
a 180 degrees worth of coverage.
Which way you do it
doesn't really matter and
our algorithm will do
it in a particular way.
But there's just this trade-off
between if you let d go positive
to negative top has it negative
then only it has to go zero to pi.
In fact,
you can restrict things even more
if you make this be the origin of
your image, the top left-hand corner.
If you're going to say that your
line has to be within the image.
Okay?
Then that restricts even more
because it has to cut off that quadrant,
so theta and d are restricted even more.
But these are just choices that
you make in terms of how you code
up the algorithm.